un abogado especial que supervisará las
investigaciones del departamento de
justicia a Donald Trump que involucran
el manejo de documentos clasificados que
tenía el expresidente en su mansión de
Mara lago y sus supuestos intentos de
interferir en el traspaso Pacífico del
poder tras las elecciones de 2020
Oye firmado una orden por la que se
nombra Jack Smith como abogado especial
la orden la autoriza al continuar la
investigación en curso y a perseguir
cualquier delito federal que pueda
surgir de estas investigaciones
es catalogado como un profesional
independiente y hasta ahora era fiscal
jefe del tribunal especial de la haya
encargado de procesar los crímenes de
guerra en kosovo anteriormente supervisó
la sección de integridad pública del
departamento de justicia y trabajó como
fiscal federal y estatal en Nueva York
el nombramiento llega a tres días
después de que Trump anunciara que se
lanzará por tercera vez a la carrera por
la Casa Blanca en 2024
creo firmemente que los procesos
normales de este departamento pueden
manejar todas las investigaciones con
integridad y también Creo que nombrar un
abogado especial en este momento es lo
correcto las circunstancias
extraordinarias que se presentan aquí lo
exigen
el nombramiento de Smith pretende evitar
algún tipo de conflicto de intereses que
pueda surgir en la investigación Este es
el tercer consejero especial del
departamento de Justicia que se nombra
desde 2017 cuando el ex director del FBI
Robert investigó la campaña presidencial
de Trump en 2016 y sus contactos con
Rusia